Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie. Big surprise,
it looks like there's a new report
that Iron Fist is going to be back in the MCU,
but not the Fin Jones Iron fist from the Marvel
Netflix Defender series is in the most unexpected
Marvel TV series to Like this won't be Iron Fist
coming back in Daredevil Born Again Echo or
one of the other Marvel Netflix defenders characters
like you'd normally expect, The Defenders to come back
so it's like they're trying to bring the concept
of iron fist back but in the most roundabout way.
So we'll break it all down.
It confirms a couple of my theories
about how Kevin Feige is dealing
with the Iron Fist character just in general.
Now that we have Shang Chi
in all of those characters in the MCU,
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
We have a bunch of Marvel Netflix defenders stuff
happening in the Echo episodes.
Next week.
I'll be doing some episode videos for that too,
but they're dropping all the episodes at once,
so it'll be a little bit different
than like your normal weekly episode series.
just thankful to get all those characters
slowly coming back in different Marvel TV series.
We got Daredevil Kingpin coming back,
kicking a ton of ass in the Echo episodes.
I literally just did a Daredevil trailer video
because Marvel finally made it official
that all the Marvel Netflix series
are canon to the MCU.
One of the big Marvel producers was like,
yeah, it's all I can do.
The sacred timeline.
back when Spider-Man
no way home in Hawkeye were happening, we knew that
they were going to bring those characters back
because we literally saw them.
And I figure that at least part of Daredevil Netflix
would be canon to the new stuff.
thankfully, Marvel took it one step further
and basically said that
all that Netflix stuff is can into the new MCU stuff
they'll be doing with the characters.
still think they're going to make a few minor edits
or just omit some details or aspects
when it's convenient for them.
But mostly. It's all meant to be canon.
So if daredevil kingpin Punisher Jessica Jones
all coming back I guess it wouldn't be surprised that
Iron Fist would eventually come back at some point,
some place to we make all the jokes about Iron Fist.
I'm sure there are some people out there that probably
did like the series, But here's the thing.
This new report about Iron Fist coming back in
the MCU is actually during a Black
Panther series Marvel is releasing later this year,
which is a huge surprise.
Like I would never expect Iron Fist
to come back in a place like that, like Black Panther.
What It is written like a Canon MCU animated series.
it is way more connected to the main MCU universe
than a show like
what if, for instance, which is canon to the MCU,
but because it's a multiverse show,
it's all happening in other universes
inside the MCU multiverse, this Black Panther
series isn't meant to be a multiverse series,
more like a ground level series set in the main MCU.
So it's a little clear
about where all this stuff is happening.
It's called Eyes of Will Conda in the Marvel TV.
People gave a small preview of it a few weeks ago
when what if Season two premiere.
But they didn't post the Black Panther preview online.
The series is supposed to visit a bunch
of different versions of Black Panther across the MCU
timeline going back to ancient Will.
Conda They didn't confirm bashing,
but I'm really hoping that they should.
The very first Black Panther,
they featured him briefly in the first Black Panther
movie, like in that Prolog.
he was also the first king of the United Tribes
that formed Wakanda
after the vibranium meteorites,
multiple vibranium meteorites.
Now, because we saw the underwater one during
Black Panther, Wakanda forever with name wars, people.
he's also the first Black Panther
to make a pact with the Panther goddess boss.
so sounds like based on this report of iron fist
showing up in this Black Panther
series, it'll be one of the previous versions
of Iron Fist, not the Daniel Rand
Finn Jones Iron fist but one of the previous people
to wear the mantle and wield the iron fist.
They didn't say which version it would be.
It would just depend on which era
the timeline this Iron Fist character shows up in
there have been some odd people in the comics
who have gained the power of Iron Fist More recently,
like even She-Hulk
got the power of Iron Fist during the age of Can't you
Moonlight crossover event because they were trying
to turn Moonlight into a much bigger character.
it's basically Kaiju versus
all the other gods in the Avengers.
She was called the Iron Hulk,
but that was a very brief thing.
So I don't really count that kind of stuff.
If you're just talking about the regular main wielders
of the Iron Fist in the Iron Fist comics.
Going back from Danny Rand in present day is awesome.
Randall, who was the Iron fist during World
War Two era in the comics,
he was the first Westerner to wield the power.
Before that, everybody had been from Asia
Now the comics are kind of sketchy
on people to wield the before him.
Like there are gaps in the timeline.
They only list a couple.
there was Big Bang
when Who held the power during the 1800s? Woo!
AOC Who held the power during the 1500s?
She was also the first woman
to wield the power of the Iron fist.
like in present day we have Colleen Wing
also wielding the power of iron fist.
before her, the very first recorded Iron Fist was named
beI Ming Tinh During the 1200s,
he actually fought Genghis Khan
using the power of the Iron Fist
just to give you an idea of the time period.
so, unless Marvel introduces
like a totally new version of Iron Fist,
somewhere in those gaps of a couple hundred years
where we don't know who had the actual iron fist.
If they don't add someone new
in those missing time period,
it would be one of those
for older versions of the character.
personally, I would love to see the original Iron Fist.
they didn't really get too much into the ancient
history of Iron Fist during the Marvel Netflix series.
during Iron Fist season two.
They had some flashbacks to Conlan to show you some of
Danny Rand's history before he became the Iron Fist.
if things had gone well,
the Iron Fist series had been received much better.
And they continued,
I think we would have probably seen more Ancient
Iron Fist during season three, Season four.
but. The whole premise of this Black Panther
series is a special task force inside will kinda exist
to track down and protect all vibranium
weapons and artifacts circulating outside of Wakanda.
so the whole idea is that because the way their culture
evolved, like these United Tribes
vibranium is essentially worked into every aspect,
in every level of their culture, every type of product,
even the things that they eat.
so over the millennia,
all kinds of vibranium or full on weapons, armor,
other artifacts have been
either taken or stolen from Wakanda, presumably.
That's how this team inside Wakanda over the ages
runs into one of the previous versions of Iron Fist.
At some point during the timeline.
No idea which time period that will be
or how they feature them.
budget?
Imagine that scene
from the first Black Panther where you see Killmonger
finding the vibranium artifact in the museum?
Well, kind of basically
allowed it to be in that museum, but they had a person
from Oakland monitoring it
that Killmonger had basically turned to his side.
But before he came along, that person from Wakanda
was just keeping an eye on the vibranium for them.
so the idea is the villains all across the ages
getting their hands on vibranium tech and weapons.
And you have this team running around
trying to get rid of them.
so a lot of people are expecting
this to be an opportunity to show us ancient
versions of Black Panther because in present day,
Chadwick Boseman has passed away.
but that doesn't stop us from seeing ancient
versions of Black Panther,
because there have been different Black Panthers
for thousands of years.
that's one of the reasons why we saw a king
to choke a Black Panther during the 1980s.
Avengers during what if like, let's just do
his father, let's do
the older versions of Black Panther,
who since passed away in present day.
know, if you're
going to do that, it just makes sense to do older
versions of Iron Fist as well, too, which also steps
around the issue of Iron Fist in present day,
which Kevin Feige is slowly beginning to deal with.
because the series isn't coming out
until much later this year, probably somewhere
towards the end of the summer.
I'm hoping that they don't change it into remove
all these references to Iron Fist in the series
because it would be cool to see Iron Fist
show up in a series,
even if it is in a roundabout way
or like an ancient version of the character.
as for Ben Jones,
Danny Rand from the Netflix Defenders, Marvel said
the Netflix stuff is all canon now, like I said,
but that doesn't guarantee you will see his version
any time soon or they won't recast him or just skip
past him and bring Colleen Wing back first
because she has the power of the Iron Fist right now
in present day to Jessica Hardwick was talking about
this specifically a couple of years ago in the Shang
Chi movie came out because a lot of people were like,
Maybe Marvel will just do Shang Chi now
instead of Iron Fist.
but they're meant to be completely different
characters, completely different mythologies.
Like there's a little crossover
between them in the comics,
but that's been a more recent thing Chung.
She never really got involved with the Tournament
of Heaven, Conlan or the Celestial Cities of Heaven
or anything like that.
Jessica Fenwick said that she'd been up for a
major role in that Shang Chi movie but declined it.
I think it would have been for his sister.
She would have been leading the ten rings
at the end of that movie.
She said her big reason for turning down the role
because it would have been a solid role,
is that it would guarantee
she'd never come back as Colleen Wing, which is why
I think that it would have been his sister,
because if she would have just been playing
a background character like no one of actual
consequence, Kevin Feige probably would have let her
come back as Colleen Wing No problem,
because he's done that with a lot of other characters.
Gemma chan is probably one of the more famous ones.
Like she was in.
The Captain
Marvel movie is a completely different character.
Then she came back as a main character,
like a much bigger character during the Eternals movie.
But it sounds like Marvel is just kind of slowly
rolling all the Marvel Netflix characters
back in in Daredevil, born again will just be like
the next big place after the Echo series.
So they're kind of waiting their toes in.
Like you have daredevil kingpin stuff right now.
Then slowly the role in the other characters, starting
with Daredevil Born Again in everything that happens
after that, like
there'll be multiple seasons of Daredevil, born again,
the only other live action defenders characters
I know are coming back in the next two years
or so besides Daredevil and Kingpin
or Jon Bernthal as Punisher,
he's still supposed to be a main character
during Daredevil Born Again.
I don't know if he's going to cameo during Echo
because they've been using a lot of weird Punisher
type of language.
I'm not expecting him because there's only five
episodes, so like it's almost blink and you'll miss it.
Jessica Jones was supposed to come back
earlier during Daredevil Born Again too,
but I think they changed that because
of some scheduling issues the last couple of years.
They decided to go back to ground
and basically redo all of Daredevil born again.
So maybe they were in the second half of the series,
but eventually they do plan to bring her back.
We know a little bit more about her
We already know they're not going to recast Luke Cage
so that role is just waiting for Mike Colter
to become available again.
He's got a bunch of other projects he's working on now,
like other TV shows, so he's booked.
That's one of the main reasons why he's not back.
Also on a story level, they just haven't found a reason
to bring him back in the actual story.
so it's one of those situations
where it's when, not if he's coming back
and I think it's the same situation
for Iron Fist in present day.
Regardless of what version of your character comes back
like it's been.
Jones or they recast or they bring Colleen Wing back
as iron fist I already talked about my early theory
about what Marvel should do to bring them back,
like bring iron fist back.
But in the Shang Chi sequel movie
let me know in the comments.
If we see an older version of Iron Fist
show up during this Black Panther series,
which version of the character do you want it to be?
Remember, this is like the ancient versions
of Iron Fist there's a whole bunch of stuff coming up.
Like I said, echo episodes. Next week.
I'll be doing a couple of videos
for that X-Men 97 episodes after that.
Cannot wait to see X-Men come back.
We'll probably get a Deadpool three trailer
at the Super Bowl to Everyone click here for that
brand new Daredevil trailer video
where they announce everything becoming canon again.
And here's my new house,
The Dragon Season two trailer video and Easter Eggs.
Thank you so much for watching.
And I'll see you guys in the next one!